lo que espero hacer en este vídeo es
deducir una fórmula para la suma de una
serie geométrica finita muy bien aquí
tenemos una serie geométrica finita y
digo finita porque termina en un punto
porque en éste en el exponente n digamos
y aquí la tienen aquí tienen esta serie
geométrica tenemos la suma desde acá
igual a cero hasta n de a por r a la
casa donde r le llamamos la proporción
común oa veces también se le dice la
razón común ok y que nos dice cuando acá
vale cero tenemos a por r a la cero
donde es real a cero por supuesto pues
es una verdad esto podríamos simplemente
dejarlo como a y luego sumamos cuando
acá vale uno aporte real a uno donde
real a uno pues es simplemente r ok
cuando acá vale 2 es a por el real a 2 y
así seguimos sumando hasta a por r a la
n iv decimos que es finita porque no
sumamos todos para todos los exponentes
verdad terminamos hasta el exponente n
si no fuera finita no seguiríamos hasta
el infinito muy bien entonces digamos
que a este a este valor de esta suma o
esta serie geométrica finita ok a este
le llamamos s n ok s por suma y n porque
llegamos hasta el exponente n muy bien y
lo que quiero hacer ahorita es
multiplicar esta expresión por nuestra
proporción común que es r entonces vamos
a ver cuánto vale r
por s a la s n s sub n muy bien entonces
esto será igual incluso podemos aquí
multiplicar por r tendremos la suma la
suma de a por r pero como estamos
multiplicando por otra r entonces esto
está elevado a la k y como multiplicamos
por r entonces sumamos 1 al exponente
donde empieza en 0 y termina en
n muy bien entonces esto aquí va a ser
igual vamos a ver si nosotros
multiplicamos por r al hacer o lo
multiplicamos por r esto nos da a por r
a la 1
por r a la 1 muy bien ahora si nosotros
multiplicamos este segundo término por r
nos queda a por r por r que es cuadrada
así que tendremos a por r al cuadrado
el real cuadrado muy bien y así podemos
seguir verdad si multiplicamos este por
r nos da perdón este término de aquí nos
da a por r al cubo si multiplicamos este
de aquí por r nos da a por el real a 4 y
así podemos seguir hasta el digamos este
va a ser a por r a la n 1 entonces el
anterior sería a por r a la n
n y luego sumamos de lo que resulta de
multiplicar este por r qué es
por r a la n 1 muy bien y ahí lo tienen
entonces va necesito que pongas mucha
atención en esta parte porque aquí viene
una de mis fórmulas o mis deducciones
digamos favoritas en toda el área de las
matemáticas y la idea grandiosa es la
siguiente si tú te das cuenta está de
arriba y está de abajo se parecen mucho
qué pasa
si a la de arriba le restamos la de
abajo qué tal que queremos calcular sn -
r por s n r por s n muy bien ahorita
vamos a omitir esto estas es digamos la
anotación usando sigma porque realmente
me interesa esta parte de la derecha si
nos damos cuenta nos tomamos este
término de aquí vamos a bueno a todos
los términos de arriba vamos a restarle
los términos de abajo y tú ya podrás ver
el patrón que hay aquí verdad hay varios
que se repiten vamos a ver si yo tengo
poder real a cero
en realidad no tengo a nadie acá abajo
parecido que podamos restarle de hecho a
por el real a cero es simplemente a muy
bien y luego notemos que sí que si
restamos a los de arriba los de abajo
entonces estos se cancelan estos también
se cancelan éste se va a cancelar con su
respectivo hasta a por el real jaén es
verdad que se va a cancelar también con
el de abajo y simplemente que nos quedó
simplemente nos quedó este término de
aquí verdad que no se puede cancelar con
nadie
entonces restamos a por r r a la n 1
muy bien y aquí está todo el secreto
porque realmente ahora nos falta
resolver
digamos esta ecuación para sn que era el
punto del vídeo queríamos calcular
cuánto valía
esta suma finita de una pero más bien
esta serie finita de una progresión
geométrica entonces lo que podemos hacer
para calcular sn aquí es factorizar lo
que es lo que nos queda
tenemos ese n que multiplica que
multiplica a 1 - r
1 - r muy bien y esto es igual a lo que
ya tenemos aquí que es a menos a por r a
la n 1 a la n 1 muy bien y para poder
despejar ese n
simplemente tenemos que dividir de ambos
lados entre 1 - r ahora hay que tener
cuidado para dividir entre 1 - r
necesitamos que la r sea distinto de 1
verdad porque si eso no estaríamos
dividiendo entre 0 y eso no se vale
al hacer esto estos factores se cancelan
y qué es lo que nos queda nos queda
simplemente que ese n es igual
es igual a a menos a por ere a la n 1 a
la n 1 y todo esto dividido entre 1 - r
1 - r y esta es una de las fórmulas que
más me gusta como se deducen es muy
bonito el razonamiento que hemos hecho
aquí
ahora bien tú te podrás estar
preguntando hoy para que todo esto
porque porque es útil o porque es
interesante así que vamos a aplicarlo en
un ejemplo vamos a usar los mismos
colores digamos que tenemos la suma de
tres digamos que es tres por un medio
elevado a la k
medio elevado al acá y el exponente lo
vamos recorriendo desde cero hasta
digamos 100 muy bien entonces esto quién
es esto será igual para acá igual a cero
es tres más tres por un medio tres por
un medio
por ejemplo cuando acá vale 2 es 3 por
al cuadrado verdad y así seguimos
sumando muchos términos hasta llegar a
tres por un medio a la 100
por un medio elevado a las 100 muy bien
y entonces esto no podría hacerlo
digamos en una en una calculadora o en
una computadora pero la verdad es que es
muy latosos es muy difícil y cansado
verdad porque tenemos que elevar un
medio a la 1 a la 2 a la 3 a la 4 a la 5
así hasta el 100 multiplicarlo por 3 y
además de todo sumarlo
así que así que lo que vamos a hacer es
utilizar esta fórmula y ahí es en donde
está la utilidad es mucho más sencillo
utilizar la fórmula entonces esto que va
a ser igual esto será igual a aa que en
nuestro caso es 33 menos 3 por r que en
este caso es un medio
un medio elevado a la n que en nuestro
caso es 100 más uno que es 101 y
dividimos entre 1 - r nuestra r es un
medio así que es uno menos uno
muy bien y ahora vamos a resolver esto
aquí si podemos utilizar una calculadora
pero ya simplificamos mucho las
operaciones así que vamos a calcular lo
digamos tengo 3 - aquí abrimos un
paréntesis tres menos tres por otro
paréntesis punto cinco que es un medio
punto cinco elevado a la 101
ok y cerramos el paréntesis nos da este
numerito le damos un igual que es casi 3
verdad ahora esto está dividido dividido
entre 1 menos un medio es un medio es
decir punto 5 0.5 y esto nos da 5 puntos
9 999 muchos 9 y 7-6 acá termina con 76
entonces esto vamos a aproximar lo esto
es casi 6 muy bien de hecho ya veremos
cuando cuando abordemos el tema de
series geométricas infinitas que de
hecho si si aquí tuviéramos de acá igual
a cero hasta infinito esto sería
exactamente 6 pero bueno eso lo
dejaremos para algún tema posterior